what I was when I was about five years
old withered on 205 West 88th Street
that's when we got the house the
apartment was rated on 89th Street
because of bookmaking activity somehow
move to the eighth Street 205 West 88th
Street every three every other day my
mom is the one that got me hooked on
Chinese food we'd walk down the corner
of 88th Street and hook a [ __ ] left
on 88 towards 87th and right in the
middle of the street there was a little
Chinese restaurant that was [ __ ]
delicious best wonton soup you have an
amine that's why I discovered real
Chinese food with the metal of the whole
thing my mother was in there three
nights a week and we probably got food
delivered one night a week my mom might
take him a walk over there and [ __ ]
with the [ __ ] Chinese dudes so it was
a particular way that she had and every
day in the [ __ ] when she's going that
a way that would come home my mom would
do come a [ __ ] 20 and everything
would be perfect but one day my mom goes
in there and I'm with it and I [ __ ]
fell your waiter ain't there so we get
this other skinny Chinese dude and he's
[ __ ] like just he was not getting the
order right from my mother and then
these days my mom was going and the
mornings but she was hungover like 11 or
11:30 there was basically for the
warrant on soup and she would get like
an egg roll or some [ __ ] entree I
will always go for the wonton soup and
the pork fried rice and the egg roll on
this particular day the [ __ ] dude
comes over and he brings the wrong order
to my mother my mother's got a half a
bag of it and she takes the [ __ ] fork
and she stabs and let the [ __ ] fork
and the Chinese guy starts yelling and
all these Chinese back and my mom pulls
the [ __ ] knife and I'm in the middle
of it and my mom was like we're gonna
walk out of here but there was one
Chinese dude that liked my mom and he
came over and he walked this out and we
were 69 feet from the place that's it
and you're not allowed back in here they
wouldn't even know order they wouldn't
even let us deliver it to the [ __ ]
apartment so my mother had the balls one
day I got home from school she's got a
terrible headache and I eat that soup
you're gonna have to go over and get me
some [ __ ] food I gonna let you us out
but not allowed in there she goes
nothing I'm gonna [ __ ] disguise you
and she put like a little mustache I
must have been about five she pulled a
mustache on me and we'll have
like a [ __ ] Sinatra hat and she put
like a suit on me and she called the
order and in those days there was no
caller ID there was nothing she called
it in under a different name and I went
in and picked up the food until his day
she's 60 lines out of there she was 69
we're under there years later even after
she moved through Jersey and they still
told that she was 69 but she would go in
there and make [ __ ] if you take your
two fingers and make a pledge do both
your hands and then put your fingers
over your fingers and if you whistle
through it that's an insult to these
people my mother would put two fingers
on top of one finger and whistle at them
it'll make them go crazy the moral of
story is if you like Chinese food don't
[ __ ] with Chinese people all right
greetings from [ __ ] podcast
Ville the Church of what's happening now
is brought to you by hims just a facts
Jack it's not unusual in fact up to 39
percent of men experiences is the fun of
ending too quickly it's a nightmare you
want to maintain your erections for
longer premature ejaculation can make
men feel down on themselves creating a
vicious cycle of sexual anxiety most
guys aren't thrilled at the thought
opening up to a doctor about performance
problems that's where hems comes in in
fact it's for hems calm it's a brand a
wellness brand for men from hair loss to
help with your erection for hems calm is
their fear listen I suffer from all this
stuff I never even thought of going to a
doctor I worked it out through different
things but if he is I came quickly not
to be ashamed about what for hems does
is they connect you with a doctor online
who could evaluate you and help you
identify the right treatment for you so
do me a favor the church family you got
a special offer just to get started I'm
gonna charge you $10 so for hims calm is
gonna charge you $10 what you're gonna
do is just go to for him calm slash
cocoa to get started that slash cocoa
that's for hims calm slash cocoa to get
started the church is also brought to
you by audit [ __ ] if you want
supplements others the way to go from
the shroom tech a move
immune to the shrimp export you know I
love their protein powder you know I
love their alpha brain 100% money-back
guarantee what you do is if you've never
ordered from on it it's time for you to
go to on it right now go to the webpage
on accom take a look at their
supplements I can't help you with the
weights of the the [ __ ] bags or
anything else I could just do
supplements
I'll get you 10% off to live at the
house all you gotta do is press in
church that's it that's it that's it
Church and you get 10% off if you go
with alpha brain they had a hundred
percent money-back guarantee and they
don't even want the [ __ ] product back
and don't try to pull a Puerto Rican
scramp
don't even think about it cuz they know
how to [ __ ] you [ __ ] work go to
Hana calm slash Church if you're serious
and changing your life around and
getting your mental toward healthy and
getting your immune system up to [ __ ]
par on it calm kick this [ __ ]
meal Lee what's happening you bad
[ __ ] it's a solo [ __ ] podcast
today it's myself and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] hello we'll come and
direct that you're from the [ __ ]
Voodoo Lounge the reason why we're doing
a solo podcast I'm I've been thinking
about for the last couple days that time
which is very interesting was Mother's
Day you know it's uh you guys know it's
a [ __ ] holiday [ __ ] a Christmas
card type holiday like the card
company's made of Mother's Day and
Father's Day it's not that somebody
celebrating I mean if you're a decent
[ __ ] person you know that Mother's Day
is every [ __ ] day but for some reason
this Mother's Day I went on the computer
Sunday morning just as he was going on
and I saw how many [ __ ] people we're
dealing like what her mom's death like
my mom's been gone for three years in
heaven or five years in heaven and let's
hate today the first thing I did this
morning was called Jerry Rocha his
mother died so I called him the first
thing I did Mother's Day was give him a
call
and I could hear it in his voice it was
[ __ ] traumatizing and all I could
think about was my first Mother's Day
without my mother and to boot it's my
mother's birthday Mother's Day weekend
so it's a [ __ ] it's just I opened the
first two or three of them you don't
even know how you're gonna make it
through and this goes for you your
father to it you don't even know how you
you really want to just sleep the day
away but you want to go to bed Saturday
night and wake up Monday morning and not
even process it whether it's Mother's
Day or Father's Day it's such a painful
tale I was thinking about life you know
my mother died in the hospital my mother
didn't die in a [ __ ] car accident my
mother than dying know that [ __ ] I found
plain and simple out of 16 years old you
know I went downstairs and there she
wasn't a [ __ ] floor you know at age my
world collapsed I mean I didn't even
know what I was going through till now
and I don't have a lot of things dolfin
doing I do have one thing over you guys
and that's the ears I'm a lot older than
you guys and life experiences I mean
look at my [ __ ] face you could see
the [ __ ] map to death on my face and
it was because of those years of me
China you know at 16 you're trying to
wrap your little [ __ ] undeveloped
mind around the death of the most
important person in your life who
supposed to be the most important people
in your life your mom and your [ __ ]
dad their number-one unless you were
raised by Grandma or whatever but you
know for most people it's your mom and
dad to wrap your head around that at
that age it was tough and I'm not
feeling bad for myself I hope we came in
I thought about it I mean listen for me
it's Mother's Day every day because
every day I draw from the pain every day
I think about it every day I think about
what would my life be if she was still
around every day I think about she could
take a good look at mercy you don't your
mother is always with you I mean I came
it took me five years to accept that she
was even [ __ ] dead the five years
your mind has no [ __ ] closure like
listen I look on my phone now like
sometimes I gotta call somebody and help
with my phone and I see Brody's phone
number I've never erased him or I see my
man Merkel's phone number I see my man
[ __ ] Ralphie's number I've never
erased him and yeah it hurts a little
bit when you open it up you're like
she's [ __ ] Christ you know you you go
through sadness and then you think I'm a
joke they said or something they said
you smile you know somebody put up over
video of Ralphie a day
and I will have a computer in just
merely had a nervous breakdown of his
him doing Tommy and Snoop Dogg sitting
in the back I mean I still can't wrap my
head that he's dead to me he's just on a
long tour for me right now at this point
he said a long tour I just haven't seen
him my head with any death your head
never it takes years for you to wrap
your head around his death so it took me
five years just to come to the
realization that she was dead and I went
off the [ __ ] rails I went off the
[ __ ] handles and I couldn't handle it
yet now the pain doesn't sting me as
much unless if I really really really
get involved my mind into it like last
on the way up Laurel Canyon Saturday
night in the comedy store I thought
about it because I saw something that
said Mother's Day and for some reason I
adorn them in this is gonna be the 40th
Mother's Day without my mother 40 [ __ ]
years and guys it still hurts 40 years
and it still hurts it hurts because of
how it happened like you never expect to
wake up and see anybody on the [ __ ]
floor you never really do I I know my
mother had a problems and their issues
but I didn't think she was gonna die I
mean you never thanked you you you don't
even go there with your mind when you
look at your parents you just avoid it
when it does come up and you see your
mom and they get known you know she's
gonna die and you say to yourself no
she's not gonna die I'm leavin going
there you don't even let your mind go
there sometimes so when I see you guys
posting on Mother's Day that you're
having a hard time my heart my heart
goes out to you guys I mean I could I
saw ten people post that their mothers
that were gone three is from John bender
- you know r.i.p mom and yeah it's a
funky place to put it up whatever works
for you I'm not here to criticize nobody
cuz they put a post up whatever works
for you to make you feel better you know
for me it took years it took years
to understand what had happened for
years to understand what I was going to
do with my life I mean the 40 [ __ ]
years I'm driving up Laurel Canyon I'm
like okay I made it 40 years I did this
for my life I did that with my life I
cleaned up a little bit I'm not a
[ __ ] common thug anymore but I still
miss my [ __ ] mother how did I survive
without her for 40 [ __ ] years
when she first died listen guys and I
said to you I've said this to you guys
from the heart before I wanted to die I
just didn't have the balls to pull the
trigger I did everything I could to
[ __ ] die I didn't take care of myself
I did drugs you know I did everything I
could tell myself that I was somebody
though you know from 1979 to 1991 in my
mind I had no [ __ ] value I mean none
at all and I let a lot of you guys are
going through a young age from the age
of 16 to the age of 30-something my life
had no value in my mind if it was if it
was money-wise my life was worth a
nickel
that's I'm telling you this right now
now it's not worth any more but I have
more value on myself then I had between
the ages of 19 and 31 at the age of 31
yeah I found comedy thank [ __ ] god I
found Tommy that was my [ __ ] religion
but for for a long time I walked around
wounded and in other words I was just
spending my [ __ ] wheels till I
started doing comedy and I started
writing and I figure that somebody a
wise man named Doug Stanhope told me to
write out my life and while I was in the
road on buses I would just take a
notebook and write out my life and then
I came to the conclusion of why she died
you know you you have to break this down
in your mind as hard as it is as painful
as of this yeah a tea is gonna fall from
your eye but you're all [ __ ] big boys
now and you know when you look at me
ultimate end is that we're all gonna
[ __ ] die we're all gonna die that's
it
we don't know what we don't know
the inspiration is we're all gonna die
but you think about your parents it's
like [ __ ] I cannot believe she's been
gone for 40 years and I've made it
without 40 [ __ ] years and I've made
it without her I didn't know I had no
[ __ ] idea - Saturday night when I was
driving that that this hadn't even
happened
you know how old were you when you were
able to start dealing with it
like how many years ago I started
dealing with it when I was 24 years old
baby no I started dealing with it the
first time then it came to my mind that
she wasn't coming back I was 22 years
old so it took me from the age of 16 to
22 I thought she was like Ralphie she
was just on tour somewhere or something
like that
it's it's just so weird yeah not gonna
what I haven't had like my parent my
parent are still with us but over the
last couple years had some people that
when I moved out here to LA I worked
with them and they died suddenly it's so
and it just it's so final and it's so
quick that it's like it's hard to even
know what like what do you mean in a con
look at the Brody situation one minute
he was at the store and the next minute
he's gonna look at the Ralphie's
situation one minute he's in Las Vegas
doing the show the next minute he goes
home we don't know we don't have the
[ __ ] answers I'm just here to help
you cope with a little bit because I'm
coming from that experience as a young
man I hadn't learned and don't get me
wrong there was tons of drugs and
alcohol involved and insecurities and
[ __ ] confusion because the pain comes
on you don't even know where to come
the pain is disguised the pain is
disguised something [ __ ] else anxiety
and it's always disguised until you
manifest it
and you realize this is [ __ ] pain
that's eating me alive
you know a couple weeks ago like I told
you guys in the podcast New York was
very eye-opening for me because I
realized that I really wasn't doing what
I really really wanted to anymore I was
doing all this stuff
like I said I love doing stand-up but I
also like no movies guys I like doing
the podcast I like spending time my
family I like spending time my daughter
I like spending time at the Konami store
I let you know that I like so many
[ __ ] things I don't have that much
time to focus on just one but that's not
what we're talking about we're talking
about dealing with [ __ ] pain and how
it creeps up up on you every day for me
I inherited pain from my mother in the
sense that I saw her deal with it at the
end of the day that was when the pain of
losing somebody when there's no friends
around when the bars are closed when
you're home taking off your shoes at the
end of the night that's when the pain
would hit me the most that's why I think
people ice themselves when they go home
at night because that's when the pain
manifest and that's when you start
hearing voices and that's when you start
getting doubts I don't know because it
used to happen me the first three or
four years after my mother died guys 3
o'clock in the morning was always a
tough [ __ ] time I mean once I'd be
home and the coke would wear off and the
alcohol would start to diminish and no
matter how [ __ ] drunk you got I don't
care if you were [ __ ] pass out drunk
you'd wake up to pee and you feel the
pain coming in on you and then you wake
up the next morning you [ __ ] take a
shower you know you start thinking about
your day and the pain disappears but
once you get home at night I think
that's you know that's why a lot of us
eat late at night you know a lot of us
like with me I gained all that weight
over the years it was my late night
eating habit so I can't blame it on that
I'm not gonna tell you that it was that
but I'll tell you dealing with night
time for me a [ __ ] rough not anymore
not anymore I'm pretty solid now the
last 12 years I think the the last two
the last fourteen years I think even the
last two years of doing the drugs that's
what I caught on that's why I had to get
high at night I wasn't at all high think
about that that's very interesting I
never
hi in the daytime I've been telling this
podcast for seven years I've told
endless stories about getting [ __ ]
high the only time I would be high when
there was sunlight is if I woke if I
stayed up all night to it I was never
the type of person to just take out a
bump of coke and do it at 3:00 and he
have to do because I knew would ruin my
[ __ ] day and then have time for it I
still wanted to do Tommy that's why I
say to you guys that the comedy was my
[ __ ] religion that saved me because I
would not [ __ ] and do a bump in this
daytime Norman you and I and did I need
one or was i interested in one did I go
get coke in the daytime for that night a
million times I can't tell you how many
times I would go you know what I'm not
doing anything right now and it's better
than going over there tonight with cops
all around and when it's dark and you
get pulled over I would shoot this house
in the daytime he'd give me a package I
go home I'd put it in my [ __ ] closet
in the parking pocket and it would stay
there cuz I got back sometimes I take
the whip me to the comedy store but I
didn't need it at the Konami store I
would do it at the comedy stores of
means of entertainment or whatever I
needed when it was just me alone with
myself
that was the own even if I partied with
you even if I went back to your house
and did a few lines
I always saved something from when I got
home so I could deal with whatever the
[ __ ] was eating away at me but now in
hindsight I think about all those years
that I hate I haven't eaten one but see
the thing about me is I I could count on
[ __ ] two four hands how many times
I've gone out to eat I mean how many
times have we got the past midnight as
you know me so we went to the coral yeah
and had the cheese omelette I mean I'm
not I'm never really I've always been
very scared of eating at night but when
I was younger I would eat the [ __ ]
tonnes at night that's that was if I
didn't have cocaine it was food it was
food for me it was real interesting now
thinking about it I'd say but I would go
home at night and stuff myself I would
eat [ __ ] 10:00 a.m. which is if he
let me when I lived up to benders they
would always have Coke guts because they
had a deli in Hoboken
I would go home at night if I wasn't
high and I need myself in to the point
where you can't [ __ ] you know of
people I can't put their pants back on
like that entire [ __ ]
so you stuff you know your emotions with
food or drugs or alcohol whatever the
[ __ ] it was that was [ __ ] me in the
way you know today I today the pain
knocks on my door from time to time I'm
not gonna lie to you and now because
I've been living with it for so long i
justed it to draw on that pain so like
I've told you guys a millions of times
before I do comedy I don't do nothing I
don't do nothing I don't want to hear
nobody's voice I don't want to go to
dinner I don't want to do nothing I have
a preparation and the preparation is
well I'm looking at my notebooks at the
jokes I'm gonna say at some part my mind
just forces myself to think about my mom
I don't know why all my dad you know
with me it was the pain of my dad and my
mom my dad died at 3 so the only
connection I have to him was the early
connection you make as a baby and as a
you know a newborn whatever that
connection it's called I don't know I
read about it years ago but that was it
did it either way at me
abso-fucking-lutely I wasn't even
recovering over my dad and also my
mother died so now you got two different
forces meeting on you this is surprised
you who I ended up doing all those drugs
this is surprised you that I would wake
up like [ __ ] that guy from narcos
well then listen I would fall more on my
[ __ ] surprise you does it
surprise me
this is surprise you but I still get
high today but I smoke weed why do you
think I smoke weed for because we all
struggle with something we all struggle
with something listen I could I could go
home at night get high smoke a bowl or
bond and I could write out whatever is
bothering me it took me years to figure
out that when I have insomnia some nice
yet you have insomnia something comes on
the TV that's good maybe you drank a cup
of coffee later on in the night maybe
you drank a soda
you have to kind of caffeine you know in
some of those green rooms sometimes I go
in there they have the sugar-free Red
Bull
and I'll drink half of it before the
second show you know [ __ ] like that but
sometimes 90% of the times 85% of the
times if I haven't sought insomnia it's
because something's ruder than being in
sideways which means something's eating
away at me and I'll get up dog I gotta
go I'll [ __ ] on one of these things with
water and I won't go to bed - that
water's gone and I forced my second
[ __ ] Chinese time you know how egg
timer
yeah oh you have to flip it over that's
what you do you turn yourself with water
how long will it take me to drink 16
ounces of water and just sit here and
think and I'll write out whatever the
[ __ ] is going on in my fat little
[ __ ] brain I'll write it up and after
I write it out on paper
I make it a loud one I make an outline
of what can I do so I don't have these
feelings recurring it anymore what do I
have to do in my day time what do I have
to do in my life what try to do in my
personal life so I won't have these
[ __ ] feelings no more and right then
in there I take care of it there's no
psychiatrist there's no nothing the
wordage is round the [ __ ] notebook
and you worked it out yourself it's like
when you used to be a kid
and you'd have three plus four and you
just couldn't tell the teacher 7 you
shoot you had a show of how you [ __ ]
got to it you show me the work and
that's how you get through the [ __ ]
pain or that's at least how it worked
for me confusion I take it to a notebook
you know a decision take it to a
notebook you know even if you have to do
an Abe Lincoln close you know labeling
and closes when you take a sheet of
paper and you put a line through the
middle and you put the negatives and the
positive on the whatever it takes for
you to move forward the notebook is
there for you it might not were you
might be going Joey doesn't work for me
then talking it out with somebody but
with that same formula well the thing
that is like that is blowing my mind
right now is we're all different we all
go through different things we're all
different people but we all have moms
and dads we all lose jobs like it's did
you ever talk it's good that you have
the notebook thing but did you ever talk
with your buddies about it or or
anything like that to like
or were they too younger than to lose
their parents at that point my friends
would bring it up to me
when I was two or three years after my
mom died some of my friends who talked
to me about that night like how was I
feeling how was I dealing with it
and I broke down in front of my friends
and they never made fun of me
you know we're met with nothing wrong
with [ __ ] a good cry from time to
time
and these guys like grew up by the book
and sometimes when we were along the car
they would ask you know how are you
holding up you know and I would tell
them the truth you know if it wasn't for
you guys making me laugh I don't know
what I would have done at that age if it
wasn't for the intensity you know you
hear the stories I'd tell from the age
of 16 15 to 21 that this is what kept me
from taking a [ __ ] swan dive thank
God that I had humor in my life and it's
so weird and I handed up becoming a
comedian because I didn't know till just
recently how much humor I was a Timmy a
couple weeks ago we went to the New York
Comedy Club and Timmy and I would talk
to tell him stories about his brother
and how much I owe his brother Roger
because growing up there was a point
where yeah from 79 to maybe 80 or 80 and
a half or 81 I was dealing with it in a
druggie way you know I was dealing with
my mother's death and a drug-induced
coma way between the acid and the
cocaine and the [ __ ] speed and the
[ __ ] drinks and you know when I met
that group again I always knew Roger but
when I started hanging out with Roger
when I moved uptown when the bend is
true Mia I discovered another aspect of
life which was comedy not stand-up
comedy that sketch comedy living comedy
like I had become part of a living
[ __ ] sitcom hanging out with these
guys I'll give you an example when I
went back home I went to dinner with one
of my buddies
and I was reminding him of a story we
used to hang out at this place
it used to be Tom and Corky's but they
the one guy couldn't taking them one he
sold it all to Corky and he called Nick
Gregory's 7 Day weekend this started
like in 1982-83 it was called Gregory's
7 Day weekend and it had the loudest
jukebox in the tri-state area you
couldn't even think of that
you couldn't even [ __ ] thinking that
I saw beatings in there I saw things in
there as a child like we would be there
from the age of 15 14 and we would hang
out next to it and a pizza parlor and
you know we saw them waking it like the
other day we'd be outside eating lunch
at Nick's and lost the door would open
through the bar the bar would be closed
but the door would open the owner would
walk out when his shirt ripped it would
blood all over his shirt with a black
eye with ice on his eye he's like it's a
[ __ ] crazy night last night we were
like 7 the more I mean it was just so
his kids we couldn't wait to get in
there and once we got in there we had
become those guys that were crazy with
rice at the bartender we did a bunch of
[ __ ] but this is how the craziest part
of my life was definitely after I quit
high school so about April of 83 when I
moved out to Boulder I moved out to
Aspen the first time with Jimmy Burke Oh
April 25th 1983 I left New Jersey I was
[ __ ] nuts but I'll tell you what else
I was I wasn't a lot of [ __ ] pain
looking back at it I mean monumental
amounts of pain I couldn't deal with it
I was living in my head from LA I mean I
was lying to myself that that's that's
when you know you have pain when you're
[ __ ] lying to yourself I was lying I
was living a [ __ ] lie
and every Sunday we would go up to this
[ __ ] Gregory 7 Day weekend every
Sunday it was known that you went up
hang up you started the week [ __ ] up
and sometimes you wanna dance Sunday at
2:00 in the afternoon and just kept the
go until Monday and we would get [ __ ]
up and this one Sunday that I was like
I've had a long enough weekend I'm not
going down there tonight I didn't know I
went out but I didn't drink I didn't do
coke I used to go out in those drink two
days and drink like Irish cream on the
rocks like on the nights I didn't drink
that's what I would drink Baileys Irish
alcohol on the rocks yeah that's no
drinking
Bailey's don't do nothin teks I'll give
you a [ __ ] to sugar headache the next
day and this one man I leave all these
animals up there and the next morning I
wake up I looked at the [ __ ] the
answering machine and it's blinking but
it's my buddy Roger that I have a friend
that hit him with a [ __ ] car before
you know like when you point a car at
somebody and you're like [ __ ] around
like people got out of the way well my
friend didn't move and the car hit him
he fell off the [ __ ] thing take a
swipe of my other friend and my friend
put his arm up and he was skinny at the
time so by blocking the punch he broke
his arm oh my god
you can't write this [ __ ] so my friend
with the broken arm went to the hospital
and got treated and my other buddy went
home but my buddy that broke his arm
kept threatened them tell him he was
gonna soon like I'm gonna sue you that
sick [ __ ]
you know the business you have is gonna
become mine and the kid had a business
and the middle of Misha was Pete and he
kept saying you know that peeing your
name that's gonna stand for poor [ __ ] I
really was just tormenting this kid just
as a matter of fact and the next day my
buddy that night in the middle of night
like at 5:00 in the morning my buddy who
threw the punch the doorbell rang and he
was my buddy with the broken arm on his
hands and knees begging him not to
assume that his dad would shoot him his
[ __ ] and my buddy was never gonna sue he
was just saying that to him the [ __ ]
well I'm gonna sue you [ __ ]
I'm taking you for everything you got
this landed on his face and the kid
called me up in six the morning crying I
mean this was classic [ __ ] like you
can't write this [ __ ] ice ice and then
for the next two months we all got
together with this kid with his arm in
the cast and he would drink with us even
though that would they broke each
other's arm when they
went out and what happened to the guy
who got hit by a car he's still around
[Laughter]
he's a longshoreman oh my god his name
is Roger he's Timmy's brother oh my god
so we walk kept it in the family
like it was a tremendous he went flying
and patan see my buddy had a business
and he would put cones in front of his
business because she couldn't park in
front of the business and my friend
pelican would stand on line get [ __ ]
up standing outside in front of his
father his mother he would run over the
cones just stomp even give a [ __ ] who
was out there my friend would run over
the cones this one on for years or he
would beep out he beat that how you
doing today you know they would keep
[ __ ] driving I had friends that took
my mind off the pain that's the point
I'm trying to tell you that the the pain
couldn't live up to there but at night I
still had to find the way to deal with
it that was the tricky area and for
years that's what I went for just to
pass out drunk pass out drunk pass out
drunk I would wake up and hit me vomit
on my shirt and that's why I stopped
drinking that's why at the age of 19 I
had to stop drinking when I moved to
slow mass because I would drink though I
was passed out drunk and puke all over
myself the only times I puked all on
myself until I was [ __ ] 20 21 a lot I
puked on people I puked on people's
clothes I puked in tons of cars cuz I
can't handle [ __ ] alcohol but I would
keep subjecting my body to it I think
I'm allergic to alcohol that is why I do
not [ __ ] drink is because what I did
to myself because the pain would make me
have to pass out drunk so it gets to a
point where you stop doing the cocaine
and the alcohol conquers you you could
do cocaine or [ __ ] night but at one
point is gonna run out and then all of a
sudden all that out all you drank is
gonna catch up with it and you got you
pass out so when you snorting when
you're drinking if you're snorting coke
with it the alcohol is kept to a minimum
like you can't believe you're drinking
what you're drinking that's right hard
they suffer see like you can't [ __ ]
believe what you drink you can't believe
the numbers
of beers that you're drinking and then
you go wait a second you stop doing coke
the coke ends and all of a sudden that
beer shows up like a ton of [ __ ]
bricks fog and you just wake up you know
and I was laying it with a [ __ ]
tremendous headache because now you're
processing that alcohol and that was
your plan every night that was my plan
to pass out drunk looking back at it do
you wish you had talked to somebody or
do you wish you'd gone to a priest or
just someone had to work it out or two
things two friends have thought there
hey I thought what I had a priest
couldn't help me or a psychiatrist
couldn't help me this is what I thought
I didn't think that there was no way
that you can help me at that age being
that young I did not know and then once
I found the way to deal with that I got
married divorced and I lost my daughter
and that strung up all that [ __ ] pain
plus you know plus [ __ ] guilts plus
all that [ __ ] you know from from 95 to
maybe 2003 I was living in a pure hell
that I had put myself in of anger pain
over my door the pain over my mother it
was all mixed in like a hurricane so
what I tell these stories about don't
blow this is what fueled it this is what
was it took me about till - took me
about to the age of 40 guys to realize
how to put the pieces together what I'm
saying by putting pieces together is
taking the pain putting it aside so I
can move forward you know that thing
with with my ex-wife and my daughter I
had come to the conclusion that I was a
loser in 95 yeah unless you're a [ __ ]
and you don't say things you know
yesterday I went to a park with my
daughter was Saturday and I'm at the
park and there's a guy doing jumping
jacks
[ __ ] kids playing around and push-ups
and jumping rope I think I'm the monkey
bars I eventually had to say something
told that this is a kids park this isn't
a [ __ ] exercise park the parents you
know he was something from a different
country wasn't American and he had a ton
of [ __ ] Cologne on it's that Cologne
on top of yeah and he's [ __ ] sitting
in I'm like hey man I don't mean to be
rude you can't there's a whole park here
you can't be doing this exercise out
with a jump rope oh Jesus and I had to
[ __ ] say something to him as a man
you know he looked at me like I had
three [ __ ] heads away and I walked
away from and but he just did not know
if that answers your question when I was
going through all that [ __ ] early on in
my life I didn't know that there was
options I just dealt with it I don't
think anybody will understand and listen
I just contacted an old friend of mine
maybe a year ago he was the therapist in
the halfway house okay and when I he was
a friend
he had become a friend to me because I
was dear friend to his brother in the
car business so he was a psychiatrist to
kind of just sign the paperwork for me
you know I'm saying like he knew I had
problems but then after I got separated
after I got divorced we got into a few
arguments on the street so part of my
thing was to go see a therapist and I
paid him basically to just sign the
paperwork for me and I would have to go
was like huh
you bought like a chunk of ten visits
right and that's what I would do but
then I started going to him and I was
angry you know him and I we used to go
to lunch afterward and we would say you
have to figure out how to work out this
anger well it is kind of crazy because
how old were you when he got divorced I
was 20
eight so you got basically just started
dealing with your mom's thing I just
started dealing with my mom's thing I
had just started basically dealing with
life Lee I had just come out of [ __ ]
be in the joint I was learning how to
deal with life on life's terms
but I couldn't because I had all this
pain swirling around and then I get
separated I get into comedy part of the
reason why I forced the hand in comedy
was to take my mind off what was going
on you know on a reason why I love
comedy so much is because it really
really did save my life and for some
people that might not be coming if you
just might be drawing or sketching or
building [ __ ] fireplaces you know
something else you have to find what
brought me that genuine happiness of
doing not even fill the money and I
didn't know about these things guys
don't think that I knew about these
things before I got I didn't know that
County was going to take off from my
life the way it did I was a type of guy
wouldn't Bend though for a piece of
paper fighting yet paid for it
do you know how was that type of a low
life if you're not paying me for it I
ain't gonna Bend there was nothing I
enjoyed doing
I didn't wanna get paid for the only
thing I enjoyed doing was doing coke and
drinking and smoking pot so what what
was it about comedy wasn't making people
laugh was it make it like you doing
something that worked like what about it
was the thing that then made you happy
that I was finally working toward
something that I could see the payoff I
didn't see the payoff by going to work
for you at a bar and learning to be a
bartender I never saw the payoff of me
going to be your slave for an
apprenticeship for four years will you
give me no effect of money at all and
you make money because you're billing
for me I wanted to go into there was
something yearning inside of me some
people call it the spirit of
entrepreneurs and I call it suck my dick
I call it taking control of your life
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
you could suck my dick I'm talking about
I got on stage and on the drive home I
realized
this is what I wanted to do I had
watched enough of it I had at that point
you know I was a fan I wasn't as as fan
as a lot of you guys are I take my hat's
off for you
you go see Theo you're gonna see Joey
you're gonna see Burt you go see [ __ ]
Segura
you guys are real comedy fans I wasn't a
fan like that still I still have my
criminal life and you know I go to a
comedy show and look at your wife's
Percy - come to sit down this is going
God God it's out of the park so I I
never put myself in those situations but
what was it about comedy and filled that
void it made me feel like I could do
something I thought I could do something
when I bartend I didn't want to give
drunks [ __ ] drinks once you realize
what you're doing as a party just giving
drunks more [ __ ] drinks right you
know I didn't even like alcohol I didn't
like being around that why was I
bartender I did the plumbing I did the
construction I did the drywall I did the
[ __ ] Donald the laborer I did
everything I could and nothing filled
that void the comedy filled voids that
were imaginable to me that I thought I
would never [ __ ] sell you know it
made me stick to something nothing I was
thirty like that dirty years old 31
years old and I couldn't stick to
anything guys anything because of the
[ __ ] pain and taking like nothing I
couldn't focus you know I would focus
for two days yeah this see me I would
take a warehouse job and then after
three days I go there's got to be
something else there's got to be
something else and when I got involved
with the comedy don't get me wrong
at first listen man I was really angry
at my ex-wife and my daughter and all
that I'm not angry anymore
they did me a favor they gave me the
gift of having a life they let me by me
trying to become a comic to appease
because yeah I became a comic to just
get drew but there was a little part of
me that hoped I could do something with
my life
so I could go back and win her level but
you know what ended up happening I
didn't get her love and I won my love oh
I won the respect of myself for myself
so in the process of looking for
something else I found something else
that was more than I could even forever
[ __ ] imagine because I never had that
for myself here I was getting on buses
booking gigs was that becoming rich not
even close but I was doing it all myself
for years I was waiting for this guy to
discover me and this guy the [ __ ]
give me a job making 80,000 a year it
wasn't like that no more I come to the
conclusion that nobody was gonna do
anything for me unless I did it myself
that's it
this is [ __ ] you always hear these
stories of you met a guy and he got you
a job driving a truck for 80,000 a year
and this is why you're read that I never
I got sick of that story because for
years I never depended on myself I
didn't have any value on myself I didn't
think I could put anything together so
when I got into jail I figured out once
in I got to jail and I was doing that
bookmaking thing in jail even by doing
something negative I figured out that I
was good you know when I started Santa
Ana maybe I'm over-exaggerating it I
started feeling good about myself when I
started selling cause there was little
spark in my eyes right and I'm glad you
brought that up it's because it's the
cars thing and the comedy I think are a
little a little bit different because
comedy takes a lot longer like I it made
me feel good but what was it hard to
stick with it for almost 30 years
because cars you could sell a car your
first and but the toughest realm of
comedy is the first 10 years
once you hit 10 years and you come to me
and you go nothing sir--nothing I'm
gonna quit that's when I have to beat
you up you already went through the
[ __ ] shitstorm this is you went
through boot camp for some people boot
camp is five years for some people boot
camp is eight years and for some people
boot camp is two years but some people
boot camp
six months for some people it's ten
[ __ ] years but once you do ten years
or something you've put whether you put
ten years into something or for once you
put four years into something that means
that if you live to 40 you did something
for 10 percent of your life you know so
once you do something for four years I
don't want you to quit like you already
went through the toughest toughest
[ __ ] windstorm you went from getting
on stage you went through getting
material you went to getting your
feelings hurt for people not putting you
up when they gonna put you up for people
saying to get them to do a podcast and
you get they're not there for people to
[ __ ] on you and tell you they're gonna
pay you 50 bucks and they really gave
you 10 the people who took you on a gig
and left you there because they met a
chick you've already been exposed to so
many [ __ ] negatives you can't quit
now
you've already slept in a car for a year
you've already [ __ ] been broke what's
the difference you're not going for
money you're going for happiness and
then the money will come and if if tommy
was I ain't mad at nobody who gets him
to stand up and says to me hey man at
the 8 year mark I figured out that doing
stand-up wasn't for me but I wrote a
book and now they were [ __ ] author
because taking that path opened up
another path like when I said T about
comedy when I got into comedy I got the
comedy to do something and to come back
and win the love of my daughter well in
the meantime I missed all that I lost
that right to get the love of my
daughter but I got something more
powerful than the love of my daughter I
got the ability to love me I started
loving me for who I was Wow and even
though I was still doing blow and I
still had a lot of problems it took a
lot a while it took a while for me they
started loving me more more and more and
I got all the way up to 418 pounds I
really wasn't loving myself that and I
was doing coke and I made a mental plan
if I get off the coke everything else
will follow and I started with the coke
and then I you know three years later I
went to Weight Watchers and here we are
160 pounds lighter you know and it all
started with that first little move at
all it took
don't listen to 10 [ __ ] years what do
you want from me I don't care how long
it takes all I care about is that you're
on your journey I stayed on that journey
yeah you're gonna have bad weeks you're
gonna have bad weeks in this life
whether it's comedy carpentry banking
selling insurance you're gonna have bad
weeks and good I just want you to love
what the [ __ ] you do before you worry
about the money I'll let you love what
you genuinely do that pain you have from
your childhood all that [ __ ] that
you keep you know I don't like
psychiatry me not gonna tell you why
yeah because you keep picking at the
scab I don't want you to keep picking up
the scale I want you to put it in front
of you deal with it and let's move on to
the next [ __ ] hurdle I don't want to
go so tell me about your father well
when I was 8 my father smoked pot
outside my window how did you feel about
that you didn't give a [ __ ] you were too
busy nouriel's and building a model or
playing a [ __ ] video game but now
because I put you on the spot you're
gonna have to say well I felt
disrespected you didn't feel anything
you thought your father was [ __ ] crazy
I thought my mother first time I smoked
pot I was embarrassed from my mother
first time I realized my mother smoked
pot I was embarrassed for what but then
you it's your mother you accept it and
you shouldn't feel anything do you feel
that yeah that's what I didn't like
about therapy I had guns like I said I
was forced into therapy by the halfway
house and I went to a rehab Reza
non-residential rehab when I gave him a
hot UA and I didn't like how they would
pick my scabs when there was no scabs
there we're just opening up a woman
we're just opening up a second fire one
for the doctor tomorrow and he opened up
my shoulder and stuck his hand on there
there's no bumps on it you feel a bump
no then why are you opening the [ __ ]
thing up do you think if you open if you
open up a wound to try to fix it jeez I
did do you think that would help or I
mean it's not for
everybody let's say the [ __ ] plumbing
is working let's say one day your
plumbing is a little [ __ ] up right and
you fix it and after it's fixing it's
working for ten years one day you open
up that [ __ ] wall and go in there
again just to see if something is
working
let's now tree fix it let's not visit it
you know traumatising times in my life
that I could break down in front of a
thing when I saw my neighbor beat up his
wife traumatizing times in my life when
I found my mother on the floor you know
I saw my dad step my stepdad shoot a guy
at 148th Street I buried a kid in the
8th grade I buried another day dear
friends when I was a sophomore I buried
another guy when I was you know
something you know they've all taken
pieces of chunks of me you know Ralphie
last year do you deal with it and you
put it away like I said I haven't come
to grips with Ralphie yet I don't think
I really don't think so you know the
other day I saw a picture down regular
Danny be uncool open up it was his
birthday I cried that kid used to drive
me to comedy shows in the beginning and
take care of me give me lines of coke
and [ __ ] make sure I got to the gig
in time all these things I can go to a
therapist and open up that scab I can go
to a therapist tomorrow and go I want to
talk about that wrangle and give her a
buck forty a week for a year like a
toddler having regular stories even
though I've come to terms of down Rago
there's nothing I could do to bring him
back we would dear dear friends he knew
I [ __ ] loved him he knew I loved him
and he knew I was grateful if he's
watching over me right now
he knows I'm grateful what he did to me
I made I turned it into something his
investment became something so I'm at
peace with that angle you know I'm at
peace with my mother she wanted me to
become a man to be a man what does that
do the [ __ ] twenty chicks know to love
my wife that they have a daughter to
respect my friends to to get up in the
morning to [ __ ] treat people with
perspective to be kind and help people
out when they're in a mess you know your
buddy came down last night Eric who I
love dearly
you know you and Eric never asked me for
a spot The Comedy Store I call you and
give it to you right
that's part of the comedy karma that's
part of life's Karma
I can't take hey every week but I give
you hope
that's what comedy is comedy life is
listen just when you're down on comedy
you got a spot the original I do that
for you every three weeks because I want
no matter how bad shitty and even if
you're gonna embalm doesn't matter who
gets to go to the original room at a
Monday night not too many [ __ ] people
I don't do that because I'm being a nice
guy I could you know I could do that
I've never said this to you in front of
people that I could do you know what we
do at the Comedy Store but every couple
weeks and call for you and then a week
later I call for Herrick and that's to
give you the same opportunities that
were given to me not at the Comedy Store
but by a guy named Jimmy of Baelor in
Denver when I was stuck doing shitty
[ __ ] open mics not I didn't have to
pay for him in those days but what I was
to get stuck going to [ __ ] poetry
nights and going to karaokes and going
to the bold the theater and bombing I
would always get a breath of fresh air
from Jimmy a beta and be paid and I
never ever ever forgotten never ever
when I do done when I think I'm gonna
call Jimmy I haven't told him yeah I
want to surprise him because I never
forgot what he did for me he didn't make
me a star you didn't make me money he
gave me an opportunity to feel good
about myself every couple of weeks he
would throw me he's the one that got me
on them and see it tour with HBO Wow
he's the one that got me you know these
20-minute spots when I really had eight
minutes he would fight for me to do 20
and stamp this stick it out what do you
think it is about comics that they
forget about that because we're talking
with segura the other day about about
Sam Tripoli and right after the podcast
he had me up another he gave me a spot
later this month well and it's a there's
a lot of people who like I was in Vegas
and there was a show that I could have
got on the guy knew me but I'm not
really a bit dry and there's nothing I
can really do for him so he didn't put
me on and it's like why why do some
people only help out people who can help
them and either pee
we'll remember what it's like and they
help out everybody because some people
actually forget they forget themselves
they forget who they are they forget
what they've become I know that I was
blessed I was you know some [ __ ]
jerk-off made a remark at me a couple
days ago about you're just really lucky
that you Metro can again some [ __ ]
jerk-off that doesn't know anything
about the work process so well it goes
into even being a human being
you know it's how I look good he doesn't
even have an idea one listed be a
[ __ ] human bait and I hit home you
know wasn't rogue and I presented the
opportunities it was the twenty he is I
stuck with it you know Rogan came into
my life I was told calmly nine years I
was already convinced I was doing this
Rogan put me on as a feature I failed
them and it took me two years to get
back into the rotation and then we never
stopped he was very good to Hari he was
very good to Duncan and I speak to those
guys all the time and we've never
forgotten about our own can did to us
but we also did something that a lot of
people don't do we did our own thing
John do your own thing God do your own
thing because once I feel you were
imposing on me that's what comics don't
like right when you start calling them
up and going hey you're gonna be in
Minneapolis mainland people who have the
balls in fighting you're right for the
gig I'll call you yeah I know who's
right for this gig I've been doing it
for [ __ ] 28 years I know who's right
for this gig once you call me you lose
me once you call me you lose me I know
who's right for this game I've been
doing it for a long time I know the
audience and I want to brighten
somebody's day the same way it was
Brighton for me you know your friend
came up to me saturday at the store--
very happy Chelsea
oh yeah Skidmore I see Chelsea's [ __ ]
working
I see Chelsea's making her move I see
she's doing videos she's doing podcast
you know you know who's faking the funk
you know we had a friend that came out
here that wanted the world giving at it
and when it wasn't giving at him he
disappeared he ain't getting onstage
normal that's how I knew I was correct
because he didn't love this he wanted
somebody
hand them this you know the kid that I
had a blocked on Facebook the other day
I had to block him because every time he
hits me up it's always for something
it's always a backhanded remark it's
always guilt you know I need he I mean
this kids telling me how he needs 10,000
hours to move to San Diego what's it got
to do with me
alright then he makes this that he lives
here why is wrong he asked me nine
questions in a row then I couldn't give
him an answer to because I don't get
that involved with Rogan that's why
Rogan and I are friends cuz I've kept it
light over the years but to get back to
your question you can never forget what
those first ten years of your comedy
life were like you have to about saying
hand somebody two golden keys to the
palace but you gotta be there for the
younger guys be there for them sometime
it's just being there shaking their hand
hugging them is enough for somebody you
know and talk to like to be honest I see
that I know the shows that you guys do
with tripling at the store on the
mainland I've been very lucky that I've
been able to do some shows in the main
room I know and I know in my head that
I'm not ready I'm like I'm obviously not
at the level to being on those shows
what I like to be a that like I would
love to go I look at those posters on
the kind of camera time on those you
know you're never gonna know you bench
350 pounds if you get back if you don't
try to write no Tripoli doesn't give me
those spots to make you start Tripoli
get you those spots to do the same thing
I too to give me an experience we know
that nine of the ten percent you're
gonna bomb right if you do well it's
it's in your favor but we know we just
want to let you get very impressive
those guys Dean Delray offered you work
yeah I've seen the people that offered
you work is the same people I've often
worked so you create this little family
in this constant flow and that's just
the way it is if that's not the way it
is in your life then you can't this
isn't for you you know I don't have I
have 20 friends and Atomics that really
work hard that really need to work
that's who I throw work at regardless of
what you might you might don't know what
you might think you're doing I see that
you're spinning your wheels I know who's
really waking up in the morning I know
who's [ __ ] thinking about
this and you can't give him the keys to
the castle but you could take him there
and show him what's in there through the
bars that's what I've tried to do with
you and with Eric and look at Dien dowry
me and Dean started [ __ ] around three
years ago look away he's come look at
cake Quigley where she's come because I
understand what people need is a pull
you know and they're doing it on
themselves I'm not doing [ __ ] for them
right I'm not doing anything at all
they've done it for themselves I took I
took him to Green Bay knowing that he
was in the kick-ass Dean and they would
be booked and that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what happened
they rebooked them he's coming back in
February up in a Milwaukee okay I know I
know what level you're up to I know you
can handle I know what you've been in
front of and for the people who say like
for the Rogen thing there's been plenty
of people who have been on Rogan and
haven't had their career explore so they
know those it's the door is if the door
is open for you it's what you're gonna
do with that door being opened that's it
it's like doing the HBO it's like having
an HBO special it's like being put on
The Tonight Show and the [ __ ] 90s you
did great on the show it's what you're
gonna do with it when I've gone on a row
game I've always expressed my feelings
from the heart I've never [ __ ] you
know I tell her how it is all wrong and
I didn't expect this [ __ ] to happen but
it's not only it's stuff I did on Rogan
it's the stuff I do on cigar it's the
stuff I did on Duncans it's the stuff I
did when I had Felicia's the stuff I did
with you it's just the movies I did it's
the radio shows I did
it's the podcast I did it's the TV shows
I did and finally all that threads
together that all threads together all
that [ __ ] that you didn't think you did
years ago actually starts to become
something it becomes part of a [ __ ]
threaten you go ah
so when I did that show in 98 that's how
I read it all becomes a threat there's
an expression that everything is
everything it really [ __ ] this at the
end of the day it really [ __ ] is
everything we do matters for their final
fun it's like a funnel we just go around
we just keep pouring shooting there
we're just making the right [ __ ]
chemicals right so and and do you think
it's all so hard because like let's say
you wanted to just give me the key or
whatever is when you're the way you did
it
maybe not work for me I don't work for
you I know for a fact it won't work for
you that's pretty crazy I can't give you
I can't take you on the road I can't
because it's not gonna work you're gonna
forget about the work that you need to
be done and eight years from now you're
gonna fall back on that you're gonna
have to go do that work so you might as
well do it now and get it over with and
you you know you I know I know when
you're suffering you'll have that look
on your face that Ralphie had that I had
that Ricky Cruz had that you know
Sebastian Maniscalco had that Steve run
is easy I had that re-add there's a
certain look on your face then it looks
like you're gonna [ __ ] vomit and I
see that look on your face for years
straight and you move forward that's
when you know that you ready there's a
point where you're you know Steve Simone
was going through recently deep delray
went through recently there's a point
where there's a sticking point you're a
featuring and you're a good feature you
don't know how to get to the next level
this is levels and this is time you know
and this it's like anything else
it took me 20 [ __ ] years to
acknowledge my mother's death and put a
spin on it so I can act deal so you
could deal so you didn't have to do that
line of coke so you didn't have to do
that [ __ ] pill you have to it takes
time to get something control it and
then give it a story so it makes it
digest into your system a lot easy and
you never never never worry about it
again and that's the Wednesday
[ __ ] morning podcast I like it
just a little pain if you had a rough
Mother's Day listen my heart goes out
there I've been down that road with you
I saw you put it down on Facebook and
this is what inspired this podcast play
that
pain is there forever don't let it
[ __ ] dictate you handle it draw from
it and execute from it and you're gonna
be [ __ ] fine the same way I was today
I'm fine I could I love to tell you that
you know I like right done you learn how
to control everything at your [ __ ]
speed not at your whatever or whatever
anybody else thinks everybody has a
certain way of dealing with things as
long as you don't kill yourself
drink yourself to death no you just
something that I'm okay with what path
you choose I really am as long as it
another fact none of those things I
don't care if you're writing that I
don't care if you [ __ ] send smoke
signals to the [ __ ] Indians however
whatever it takes for you to handle this
eternal pain of a loss one whether it's
a dad or mom you know my heart was up to
Krystal my heart was out to Bob
lowliness my heart goes out to just so
many people that have been the church
family I've lost loved ones the last
couple years my heart goes out there and
this podcast is dedicated to you guys
learn to control it it's gonna be there
for a long time and just learn how it's
with you I finally I finally came to the
conclusion that my mother stands with me
my mother is on my right and my father
is on my left and that's why I made it
to where I am today because I have this
[ __ ] angel and all I ever pray for is
that they watch after my daughter or
something happens to me so my daughter
could end up on the same path of
happiness I ended up it and that's it
you bad [ __ ] do not forget June
7th I'm at the Fillmore [ __ ] Theatre
in New Orleans oh [ __ ] and then on the
8th at the Tabernacle Theatre in Atlanta
I'm taking my boy Steve Simone down
there we're gonna be eating some [ __ ]
everything in [ __ ] New Orleans
whatever you got will [ __ ] eatin
[ __ ] so go right now to Joey Diaz
calm look at the schedule and get your
foot dotnet and get your ticket that
time that metal gives a [ __ ]
just get your [ __ ] tickets now see
you when I flop and see you before we go
I want to talk to you people buy
something
number one one of my all-time sponsors
on it they've been there since day one
with me selling supplements but
in me and I believe in them that's why
I've been with them since day one from
the protein powder to the shroom tech to
the Alpha brain let's start out with the
Alpha brain so you don't lose Nick
because if you don't like it there's a
hundred percent money-back guarantee
nootropics
get your mind going controls what you're
doing this is the way to go give it a
shot give it a shot Columbus did go to
alikom right now look at the great
supply supplements that they have from
the shrimp tank to the shrimp export to
the shrimp tech commune I don't give a
[ __ ] but if you don't believe me start
without forebrain that's that flagship
and like I said you know like you get a
hundred percent money-back guarantee go
to anaconda press in charge CH you are
CH and get ten percent off your first
want to deliver it right to your house
like I told you the beginning of the
show I'm very selective with the
sponsors and I love what forums does why
they treat the problem and they do it at
a and and of course that you could
afford you're like Joey what's for him
well let me give you the facts alright
for hims is a is a is a wellness brand
for men they offer access to physician
consultation and prescription treatments
online for common issues that men deal
with Mike hair loss stuff like that
whatever you know the fact is it's not
on user up to thirty nine percent of men
experience that the fun is ending too
quickly if you want to maintain your
erections for longer this is the way to
go because premature ejaculation can
make men feel down on themselves
creating a vicious cycle of sexual
anxiety most guys aren't girl that the
thought of opening up to a doctor about
performance positive I don't I'm not so
having a positive mental state is good
in and out of itself it could be the key
to better lovemaking and help guys gain
control when crunch time hits that's
what we call a win-win situation now
with for hims when you visit for hims
not calm you got a convenient an
affordable treatment for your early
arrival arrivals they connect you to a
doctor online that could evaluate you
and help identify the right treatment
for you best yet it could be delivered
right to your door and the discreet
package not even your wife or your
girlfriend no this means no more awkward
in-person doctor appointments
if you want to slow down your roll and
make the good times last go to four hens
calm they also help you with hair loss
they also help you with erections if you
have a man problem for hims can help you
okay right now special time only for
hims is offering you the church family a
special offer you get started on four
hymns for just $10
joy what are you talking about ten
dollars ten dollars I'll get you started
on four hymns calm right now just go to
for him calm
/ Coco that's four hymns calm and / Coco
I'm gonna save your money time
aggravation face and you're gonna be so
happy that I rights feed you the forum's
calm you're probably gonna send me a
Twitter go Joe you're a [ __ ] genius
yes I am because forums has the solution
to your problems whether it's hair loss
dysfunctional penis or you're coming too
quick they can help you out right now
just go to four hands calm / Coco to get
started that's four hymns fo r hims calm
/ Coco C website for full details and
safety information listen I want to wish
you a good [ __ ] weekend have a great
time I want to thank for hymns I want to
thank on it but most importantly I want
to thank you guys for being the church
family and for listening to us and for
support and doesn't want to thank the
Flying Jew aka the Christ killer and uh
I want to just reassures all a Happy
Mother's Day to your mothers and if you
feel bad cuz it may take a few days to
[ __ ] understand what's going on I
love you guys
I'll see you tip-top Magoo next Monday
morning the [ __ ] twenty it's ready to
[ __ ] rock check this [ __ ] melee